hey um so i agree with
almost everything you said um what i
wanna what i wanna ask about
is um i'm not qualified to speak on the
uh morality of abortion as other people
sometimes do but
um logistically speaking using the
numbers that you
set forth the 1.3 million um babies
every year
that are killed if you per se outlaw
abortion what what do you now do with
those
1.3 million babies because i would i
would assume that it's not
two loving heterosexual parents that um
are you know financially stable and
ready to have a child that are the ones
that are having these abortions it's
usually
um i think single moms and stuff like
that and as you
talked about when you talked about
marriage that's not a good way to
have a child and that's not a good way
to uh
have children in this society yeah so
you're talking about the socioeconomic
concerns of abortion yes um i you know
my first answer to that
is is um i don't care uh
well i mean seriously because that could
never justify killing people
so even if you could show me this
crystal ball some vision of the future
where abortion is illegal
and we are all living in destitute
poverty then i would say yes let's do it
let's do it now
because i would rather live in a poor
country that doesn't kill babies than a
rich one that does
so um
but i would also say as to the
socioeconomic thing that
yes i think if we were to outlaw
abortion across the country
overnight which of course wouldn't
happen but if it did in the short term
there would be
an adjustment and there would be
difficulties financially well worth the
price
uh worth any price in my opinion but in
the long term
i think it would help our country
socioeconomically and in every other
sense because think about it with
abortion we
have separated um the life-giving aspect
of sex
from from the you know the pleasurable
aspect of sex and and what
and what that does it encourages people
to engage in sexually
risky and irresponsible um
behavior more and more because they know
that you know at the end of the day they
can always just get an abortion
if you take the abortion out then over
time people are going to be encouraged
to be more responsible in their sex
lives and they're going to be encouraged
to get married
preferably before they have sex or but
if not then you know once the baby is
on the way they get married then like it
used to be done so i think i think over
time it would have the effect of
strengthening the family
which would um therefore strengthen the
economy
economy as a secondary kind of benefit
so
thank you thank you